so I guess I will start by first of all
congratulating you all since the last
time I've seen you you've all
regenerated your intestine so it's like
you're a brand-new person okay so so
there's that I want to start the lecture
by talking about something I've been
putting off telling you about which is
the Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine that was awarded this year and
it was awarded to James Allison and
tasuku hangzhou for their discovery of a
way to harness the immune system to
fight cancer okay and we're gonna talk
about the immune system later in the
course
and it turns out I I will lecture on it
and I've actually had immunology and in
fact I had immunology with James Allison
so I will do my best to channel James
Allison when I talk about the immune
system but what what they won the prize
for is they figured out a way to
essentially release the break on the
immune system in order to allow the
immune system system to better fight
cancer okay and this is a technique
that's been used in the clinic and there
are currently a number of clinical
trials that are also looking to see
whether this can be used in a variety of
different cancer types okay so I just
wanted to point that out now because
we're talking about cancer and I'll go
more into the mechanism is how this
works when we start talking about the
immune system so as I mentioned in the
last lecture cancer is basically a
progressive loss of tissue organization
and luckily for us our body has a number
of different barriers to cells becoming
cancerous and forming a tumor and so I
wanted to start out just by having you
guys tell me what you feel the barriers
would be
to this process so who has an idea of a
barrier what are the barriers in place
by your body to prevent cancer cells
from arising and forming a tumor and for
this process to form a malignant tumor
what's that Oh Rachel sorry apoptosis is
a good one
right so there's a careful process right
in the in your body to limit how long
certain cells are resident in the body
and all of this depends on communication
between different cell types in your
body so so barriers to tumorigenesis and
one type of signal is a survival signal
and if a cell is not getting a survival
signal then the cell will undergo
apoptosis which is what Rachel was
referring to right so one barrier is
that there is a highly regulated system
of determining whether or not cells
divide and also whether or not cells
live okay so there are growth survival
signals which means that the decision
for a cell to sort of go off its rocker
and just start dividing uncontrollably
is not likely for a normal cell
something has to happen to that cell in
order to perturb it okay so what are
some other barriers to sort of forming a
tumor and for that tumor to become
invasive yes Jeremy yeah so the this
cancer cell can't activate the immune
system so you could have some type of
immuno suppression of the cancer
and I won't talk about that today but
maybe we'll come back and talk about it
when we talk about the immune system
okay looking looking at this diagram
when the cell proceeded when the
tumorous proceeds to invasive cancer
what do you think are some barriers to
that process happening what are cells
new normally doing in an organ right the
cells that line your intestine are they
like invading into the surrounding
tissue no Jeremy's shaking his head no
right so normally cells don't do that
right or certain types of cells do but
normally if you have cells that are the
lining of an epithelium they're not like
going and going off to a blood vessel
okay so I'm just going to sort of review
sort of the structure of the tissue and
then we'll talk about some of the
barriers that prevent this from
happening so I'm drawing a tubular organ
here right this could be the tube of the
intestine there would be a lumen inside
here it could be some ductal structure
in an organ like a mammary gland it
could be that this is the airway of a
lung and there's an epithelial lining
around that airway so these cells here
are forming an epithelial lining and one
important aspect of epithelial biology
is in mature epithelia they have a floor
that the cells stand on okay so this
structure that I just drew around these
cells in green is known as the basement
membrane all right it's the basement
because it's kind of the floor that this
other thing is built on and this
basement membrane is made out of what is
known as the extracellular matrix which
I'll just call matrix right now the
extracellular matrix are base
Stickley extracellular proteins that
form a meshwork
that forms a rate rigid structure on
which epithelial cells can sit on okay
now if we think about what surrounds
this organ there's there's also matrix
proteins and sort of intervening areas
and this is known as connective tissue
okay and so if we think about the cells
that are the epithelial cells here they
are in one state and this state is known
as epithelial as I just said so these
are both alleles epithelial cells have a
few properties that are really
distinguishing the first is that they
have high intercellular adhesion and the
next is that if you consider their
relative mobility you know they can
obviously move within the epithelium
because we talked about the intestine
and how cells are moving from the base
of the crypts up to the villas but in
general these cells aren't moving in and
out of the organ okay so I would say
that they have a low migratory potential
okay and so these are the epithelial
cells that are here now there are also
cells that are in this interstitial
space and I'll draw they often have this
highly elongated morphology and these
cells are in a fundamentally different
state okay and this state is known as
mesenchymal
or stromal so this area sort of outside
the organ is also known as the stroma so
there are known as stromal cells in this
in this location and these cells have
very different properties than
epithelial cells and that they have low
adhesion I should say low cell to cell
adhesion and in contrast to these
epithelial cells these stromal cells as
you see in this example up here for
that's a human neutrophil these stromal
cells are highly migratory so that
neutrophil is chasing a bacterium and
they'll eventually get it but the movie
will loop and so you'll see it
constantly chasing that bacterium okay
so some examples of stromal cells would
be immune cells like this human
neutrophil and you probably know that
immune cells have to traverse different
organ systems they have to be rapidly
recruited to sites of infection or sites
of injury and so this type of cell has
is fundamentally different from the
types of cells that line your organs
where you basically need those cells to
stay put okay when considering cancer
right you have these different types of
cells in your body 90% of cancer comes
from a cell of epithelial origin okay so
90% of cancers are epithelial and origin
okay some other examples of stromal
cells are cells like fibroblasts and
fibroblasts are cells that secrete and
remodel the matrix that's in connective
tissue and they're also important for
wound healing and secreting matrix
during the wound healing process okay so
that's just to give you a few examples
okay so now let's come back to this
example and talk about how is it what
what happens to get a cell to go all the
way from being a normal epithelial cell
to having this type of behavior where
initially you have growth and a loss of
the control over growth and survival
signaling and eventually the cancer can
become what's known as malignant and
what's known so it's a progression and
initially you might just get increased
in cell division and abnormal cell shape
which is known as dysplasia and at that
point the it's known as something like
an adenoma or something that's benign
but it's this last point here up here
where the cells breach this basement
membrane that's when that happens then
the cancer is known as carcinoma and
it's on the lignin
so malignant look malignant cancer is
cancer that has breached the basement
membrane
all right so I want to sort of take you
through the progression of tumorigenesis
and first I'm gonna start with the
breakdown of this growth survival
signaling and I just wanted to remind
you about what we talked about with the
intestine as our model organ and in the
intestine remember that this is all
regulated by signals between cells and
like stem cells and niche cells so the
niche cells are sent sending the stem
cells signals like wints that control
their self-renewal and then it's the
loss of this signaling that allows these
cells to eventually undergo apoptosis
and get shed into the lumen of the
intestine okay so one of the first steps
in cancer is this breakdown and growth
survival signaling so this this first
breakdown is going to enable the cells
to sort of overcome this first barrier
okay and so as I just pointed out
remember it helps to think of what has
to happen in a normal tissue or organ
normally the decision whether or not a
cell divides or death dies so cell
division and also death is highly
regulated okay and it's regulated by
communication with other cells
so in cancer this regulation goes awry
right and how would this regulation go
awry yeah Jeremy
so Jeremy suggested that there could be
mutations like oncogenic mutations or
tumor suppressor loss that lead to
abnormal cell division and death and
that is exactly right so you could have
uncle genic mutations and these
oncogenic mutations they often hyper
activate or constitutively activate
these growth signaling pathways that are
normally downstream of growth factors
and receptor tyrosine kinase a--'s and
if you hyper activate those you reduce
the dependency of the cells on these
signals okay so these oncogenic
mutations can reduce the dependency of
cells on growth factors and growth
signals okay but one important point is
that this is not enough okay and you can
think about this in the case of the
intestine because if you had an
oncogenic mutation in one of these cells
here it might not be as dependent on
signals for growth but it doesn't matter
because even though you had that
mutation is gonna die and it's gonna
shed out of the tissue okay and actually
what happens in many cases where you
activate a signaling pathway that allows
the cell to in an abnormal way go
through the cell cycle you actually
induce a failsafe mechanism at the cell
which causes a cell to undergo a p'
ptosis okay so often you get this step
happening and the cell just undergo
apoptosis because you've evolved to
protect your organs from this type of
mutation so it's the oncogenic mutation
in collaboration with loss of tumor
suppression and one of the main tumor
suppressive mechanisms our body has is
apoptosis where if the cell is doing
something abnormal the cell simply dies
okay so so loss of a tumor suppressor
could be loss of a gene that promotes
apoptosis and in that case if the cell
loses that mechanism the cell will avoid
apoptosis
okay so these are it seiz uncle genic
and the los oncogenic mutations and the
loss of tumor suppressors which subverts
the normal communication between cells
which is required for normal tissue
homeostasis okay now another example of
this growth in survival signaling is not
one which involves necessarily a genetic
change but one that involves changes in
expression and it also involves
interaction between the tumor and the
surrounding cells of the body okay so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
tumor micro-environment and this is
something that's important to consider
in cancer because you know a tumor in
the body it's not an isolation it's
surrounded by other cells in your body
and other things in your body okay like
matrix and so here's a picture showing
you a tumor and the tumor is stained
with this membrane protein which is
shown here in the rust color so that's
the tumor and what's also stained in
this in this piece of tissue is the DNA
it's stained in blue and so you see the
nuclei of the tumor cells in there but
you see all these blue nuclei
surrounding the tumor and these are
stromal cells that are around the tumor
and they've actually been recruited to
the tumor by the cancer cells okay so in
what I mean by tumor micro-environment
is just a region around the tumor okay
and so if you have a cancer and you have
a tumor the tumor cells can actually
secrete signals which recruit stromal
cells okay so there can be a interaction
where the tumor sends recruitment
signals that causes stromal cells to
come by and what the stromal cells can
do what they do for the tumor and why
this is beneficial for the tumor is that
stromal cells can secrete growth signals
or survival signals that promote the
growth of the tumor okay so there can be
a reciprocal interaction here where you
get a abnormal conversation between
cancer cells and the surrounding stromal
cells but again this is very similar if
you think about it to the way a normal
organ works right you you often have
these signals going between cells and
that is involved in normal tissue
homeostasis what's happening here though
is abnormal and that the cancer cells
are constitutively recruiting these
stromal cells just to get this growth
signal that they're addicted to and
because you have just the presence of
such a loop suggests that these cancer
cells even if they have oncogenic
mutations and lost have lost tumor
suppressors they are not totally
independent of growth signals they still
to some extent rely on growth signals
okay so these oncogenic mutations they
reduce the dependency on growth signals
but this dependency the dependency on
growth signals is not eliminated okay
and one experiment that showed this was
an experiment that was done back in the
1950s where patients with a type of skin
cancer basal cell carcinoma were taken
and they had their tumors excised from
one part of their body and then the
tumor was grafted on back onto them to
another part of their body distant from
the original site of the tumor and this
grafting experiment was done either with
the stromal cells that surrounded the
tumor or the stromal cells surrounding
the tumor were removed in just the tumor
cells were grafted back on to the body
okay now this experiment probably would
not be allowed today but back in the 50s
I guess it was legal and so the
experimental result is that if you
graphed the tumor cells with the
surrounding stroma the tumor was able to
establish a second tumor or the tumor
cells survived this this grafting
procedure where as tumor cells that were
taken without the stroma underwent cell
death when they were put in a new
location okay so there's something about
this specialized micro environment that
the tumor creates for itself that is
enabling the tumor to grow and survive
okay and the model is is that it's
because these stromal cells are
secreting growth factors that these
cancer cells are still dependent on
so this dependency on growth signals is
important clinically because some some
types of cancer there is an elevation of
growth factor receptors that are
associated with the cancer and the
famous example of that is in 30% of
breast cancers there is a growth factor
receptor the her2 receptor which is
overexpressed in the cancer cells okay
so I just drew a receptor here and I'm
now talking about the her2 receptor her2
stands for human epidermal growth factor
EGF receptor - okay so that's this is a
receptor tyrosine kinase which is a
transmembrane protein receptor it's
expressed on the surface of the cell and
so about 30% of human breast cancers are
her to posit positive which means that
the cancer cells are over expressing
this receptor tyrosine kinase the fact
that you have these these cancer cells
over expressing a growth factor receptor
suggests that the cancer is requires
some type of growth stimulus in order
for the cancer to be growing okay and
the fact that this was discovered that
30% of breast cancers overexpress her2
has been used by researchers to develop
a treatment for this type of cancer
that's her2 positive the treatment is
known as Herceptin possibly some of you
have heard of this
it was developed at Genentech and what
Herceptin is is
it's an antibody that was raised against
the human her2 protein
okay so Herceptin is an antibody it
recognizes her two on the surface of
these cancer cells and if you you can
treat patients with this antibody and
that antibody binds to the her2 positive
cells and either blocks the function of
her - or recruits immune cells to kill
those cells off okay the exact mechanism
I don't believe is known but what is
known is that Herceptin has really
changed how we're able to treat her to
positive breast cancers and it's been a
huge success story in the fight against
cancer
all right so we've talked about this
first barrier there barrier to tumor
cells becoming at least semi independent
of these growth factors and so now I
want to talk about other barriers to
tumorigenesis right and if you consider
an epithelial cell here right even if
these cells are able to grow they won't
be able to leave the organ until
something else happens and one thing
that would need to happen for these
cells to become malignant and to leave
the organ that they were initially part
of is for there to be a breakdown in the
adhesion between cells so for the next
few minutes I want to talk about the
breakdown in cell to cell adhesion okay
so how what is what a cancer cell
basically unstick itself from the cells
that surround it in order to leave an
organ and go somewhere else and for that
to explain that I have to remind you
about some of the normal biology of
these epithelial cells which we talked
about earlier which is that they express
these transmembrane proteins that are
adhesion proteins okay so normally
epithelial cells have adhesion proteins
and the famous one for epithelia or one
of the famous ones is called epithelial
or e-cat hiren and ecad hiren is a
transmembrane protein it has a
extracellular domain but rather than
that extracellular domain binding to
some secreted ligand this extracellular
domain recognizes ich adhere in
molecules on other cells and they stick
to each
and it essentially functions like
cellular velcro okay so the cells link
together and they stick to each other
such that they form a coherent tissue
okay so the way that cancer cells
subvert this mechanism of adhesion is
they have to do something that inhibits
ECOD hiren and so cancer cells what what
they can do is to decrease this cell T
cell adhesion and I'll tell you how in
just a minute and in addition to
decreasing this cell to cell adhesion
they can also promote the genes that are
involved in motility
okay so we have to understand then how
it is a cancer cell would do both of
these things and I'll start with cell to
cell adhesion and in contrast to what
we've talked about with the growth and
survival signaling where you have
mutations that happen in cancer cells
and you basically have an irreversible
change to the genome of the cell this
change in in the adhesive properties of
the cell and essentially their cell
state right because what you see here if
a cancer cell is having less adhesion
and getting more migratory its switching
from an epithelial type of state to a
mesenchymal type of State okay and what
this is called is an epithelial to
mesenchymal transition and that is EMT
for short okay and this EMT is not a
genetic change it's not caused by a
genetic change but it appears that EMT
results from changes in gene regulation
so you can think of it as more of an
epigenetic change an epigenetic
epigenetic change change in gene
expression so there's a change in gene
expression such that this can reverse
later on
okay and there are master regulators of
this process which alter gene expression
and so the type of gene that alters gene
expression these are also often called
transcription factors and there are
several transcription factors that are
master regulators of this EMT process
and their names are twist snail another
one's called slug there's an escargot
you can see this got a little out of
hand and you can tell by the names that
they probably were not discovered in
humans and in fact these genes were
discovered in the same genetic screen
that I outlined before where Hedgehog
was discovered okay so it was a genetic
screen and the flies and it was these
are genes that affect the embryonic
development of the fly and I'll show you
this this view of the fly embryo so this
is an embryo here and you see it's an
epithelial sheet surrounding the yolk
and what happens is in early stages of
development a population of cells
expressed the twist gene so that's twist
in the dark here and this twist gene
causes these cells to basically invade
into the middle of the embryo okay so
here are the twist cells now going into
the inside of the embryo and then the
cells undergo EMT and they start to
migrate around inside the embryo okay
what this is doing for the fly is that
these are the cells that are going on to
form the muscle okay and if you look at
your neighbor you might notice that
their muscles are on the inside of their
body okay so this this process is
basically putting
these cells by getting them to move its
putting the cells in the right place for
what they are going to differentiate
into during embryonic development okay
and so but this this process if
activated during cancer can allow these
cells to be more mobile mobile and to
leave one organ and go into another
organ okay so cancer isn't inventing
anything new here it's corrupting a
normal program that cells have a need
during development and it's in
activating it at an inappropriate time
okay so these are all transcription
factors and what they do is they repress
the expression or function of kid hearin
such that the cells are no longer as
sticky okay so they basically when these
transcription factors get turned on
it makes the cells less sticky to each
other and it also promotes their
migration so it turns on genes that are
important for migration this process of
EMT as I mentioned is reversible and it
also involves interactions between tumor
and stromal cells I'll show you an
example of so in the fly embryo one
thing that's nice about the Flies is you
can actually watch this happen live and
so I'm gonna show you a movie now
showing you the invasion process we're
gonna have an embryo here and what I'm
going to show you is we're looking at
the cells that are expressing twist and
snail and they're on one side of the
embryo and I'm going to show you a
section of the embryo that is this
analogous to this okay so when the cells
move inside they're gonna disappear in
this movie okay so when you see like the
crease in in the embryo that's when the
cells are invading into the middle of
the embryo and so the cell outlines are
in magenta here
and what's labeled in green is a type of
motor protein that's involved in the
mobility of cells and in this case is
involved in these cells moving into the
interior of the embryo so here you see
the motor protein appearing and that's
when these cells are going to dive into
the embryo right so it's almost like a
waterfall these cells are like moving
into the inside of the embryo through
this process of imagination and
subsequently EMT there it goes again
you can see the cells are now on the
inside okay
so this process of EMT also involves
interactions between the cancer cells
and the stroma and that's illustrated
here because what you can see what's
being labeled here you can see the
nuclei of the cells but these cells at
the edge of the tumor are up regulating
this gene which is an alpha beta
integral which I'll mention in just a
minute and this is getting up regulated
right where the tumor contacts the
stroma and this gene alpha beta
integrand is a gene that's associated
with motility and EMT so in that slide
here one gene involved in motility
as a class of genes called integrins
okay and so this also results from the
signaling between the tumor and the
surrounding cells and again this is not
something that cancer created this is
what happens during wound healing
so during wound healing if you injure
yourself the the wound recruits immune
cells and the immune cells signal to the
surrounding skin or epithelial cells to
undergo EMT in order to close and fill
in the wound okay so this is a natural
process that happens in your body that
is simply getting corrupted by cancer
cells
all right so now let's talk about this
last step of motility so this is now how
the cells would break out and move away
alright let's come back to this movie
here there are a few things I want you
to notice about this movie the first is
holy [ __ ] that cell is moving ok and so
so like the first aspect of this is
because the cell is moving it suggests
that there's some sort of force being
generated okay so there is the cell is
generating force and I'm not talking
about like some type of mystical Jedi
force I'm talking about the mass times
acceleration force okay so like a
physical force okay the second thing I
want to point out about this movie is
that you see that bacterium and it's
moving around this cell is able to
follow that bacterium so the cell and
the fourth generation process is very
responsive to the signals that that cell
is getting okay so the cell is
generating force and this force is
responsive to signals
okay so for the remaining part of the
lecture I basically just want to tell
you about how it is that the cell
generates the force required to move
itself around and it involves a
particular type of protein it's a
component of the cytoskeleton and we've
talked about microtubules and the
microtubule cytoskeleton in its role in
segregating the chromosome but there are
other cytoskeletal systems that the cell
has and one is called the actin
cytoskeleton which is showed on the side
above and actin the actin cytoskeleton
is a system that is a biopolymer in the
cell so this is a biopolymer like
microtubules and actin is a gene and the
actin gene encodes for a protein the
actin protein and when the actin protein
is made in the cell it start out as
being just a sink a single globular
protein okay and when the actin is in
this state it is called globular or g
actin okay but these subunits these
proteins can come together and form a
polymer so they can go from being
individual isolated proteins to forming
a polymer that forms a long skinny
filament okay and the this form of the
protein that's forming a biopolymer is
known as filamentous or f-actin
okay and these are long skinny filaments
they can be hundreds of nanometers even
microns in length so hundreds of
nanometers long and the filament width
is about 10 nanometers okay so I'm just
trying to give you a sense of dimensions
that this is a long skinny filament that
the cell can assemble and it assembles
into these dense mesh works which you
can see in the slide up here right so
this is the leading edge of the cell so
the cell will be migrating this way and
what you see in this in this cell is
this densely branched network and these
are all actin filaments okay so you get
this huge dense forest of actin
filaments that's right at the edge of
the cell that is moving forward okay one
thing I want to point out is like all
things in biology this is not a one-way
street
and so these bio polymers are very
dynamic meaning they can undergo
assembly and disassembly and they can do
so on the timescale of seconds one last
thing I want to point out about the
actin filament is there's a polarity to
the filament such that there's a end
known as the plus end where growth is
favored and there's an end known as the
minus end where there's often d
polymerization so you can get a
directional growth of the filament so
this is where growth happens and so in
this network that you're looking at the
way that actin is oriented so I'm going
to draw just a cell here you have this
dense meshwork of actin and in this
meshwork there's a polarity to the way
the actin filaments are oriented so the
cell is migrating this way and the plus
ends of the actin filaments are facing
out right at the surface and the minus
ends are back here
okay and so what you have when the cell
is migrating is you have this biopolymer
Network that's growing on this end but
shrinking on the other end and that
allows the cell to generate a constant
per true civ force okay so it's the
growth of actin filaments the growth of
of f-actin which generates a protrusion
no if we consider the whole process of
cell migration what you can see is that
initially you're gonna push the cell
membrane forward okay so you get a
protrusion it pushes it forward that's
often called a lamellipodia
or a pseudo pod and so this sort of part
of the cell moves forward but in order
for the cell to have a net motion
forward it then has to stabilize that
protrusion and it stabilizes the
protrusion by adhering to the substrate
so right now we're just considering a
cell moving on a flat substrate and so
the way it attaches to the substrate is
through cell matrix adhesion and this
cell matrix adhesion is mediated by
another type of adhesion receptor known
as an integral okay so the cell pushes
forward anchors itself
on the substrate pulls its body along
and then just repeats that cycle over
and over again so the the best way I can
illustrate this is if you think about it
right you get your protrusion you get
your elbow out you put down you anchor
right and it's just a repeated cycle and
it's able to migrate across the
substrate
so it's kind of like a frontal tow
mechanism okay you have cycles of
protrusion you generate traction and
then you pull in order to translocate
okay and so that's how cells are
migrating and in 2d oh this is just
showing you that cells can pull on stuff
so this not all cells migrate in this
way I just wanted to say that
so in 3d cells have other mechanisms to
migrate that de-emphasize this traction
mechanism that cells have okay so you
can get rid of all the integrins that a
cell has and they're still able to
migrate and that's because 2d emphasizes
the role of adhesion but if you confine
the cell then the cells are able to
migrate
so what's shown here are cells that are
not confined this is a confined cell in
a micropipette and you can see it's the
same type of cell but the cell can
migrate in confinement but it can't
migrate outside of confinement okay so
in this sense the cell is migrating
through a different mode and you can
kind of thinking it you can think of it
as the cells doing some type of Chimney
maneuver so it's able to kind of like
get in a confined environment push out
against its surroundings and that's how
the cell then is able to generate
traction in the absence of an integral
molecule
all right great so we are set for now
you